one legal scholar warned the members of  Congress are one day going to have to  face Alexander Hamilton and James  Madison in the afterlife yeah  after hearing this Bernie sander said  hey I already met him in this life  okay he said they're bricks  too much wine I don't distribute the  whoa  Bernie take it easy targets will be  reduced Lee that's played Bernie Sanders  impression is becoming a monkey an older  [Applause]  just obsessed with income distribution  believe it or not it's been one year  since the social media app tumbler  removed all pornographic content from  its site yeah what's not a big deal  tumblr users said hey no problem we got  real good at masturbating to Etsy so I  just had some oven mitt  I won't back off that one in a new  interview that just came out Brad Pitt  said he didn't cry for almost 20 years  yeah he said the trick is every time he  got sad he just remembered he was Brad  Pitt  [Applause]